you should have sweet you should have
seen his brow just break into a quick
sweat when you said say something about
these positions exactly I see you got
the memo though Rex real men wear pink
that's right that's right
we had exude self-confidence we had
called each other in the morning as we
always do and coordinate our wardrobe
now you know I'm kind of limited in what
I'm able to say here because just before
I walked in here Jen said don't say
anything stupid well there goes my whole
script well we know you can come up with
some fresh material I hope we saw garry
kasparov come in here and talk about the
Grantchester and the exciting gains from
this year's Sinquefield Cup after last
year's sync to the cup which which is
also very exciting could you have dreamt
that these great players would come here
and it would just be these scintillating
games no I couldn't what's really
amazing is this is analogous to the
investment world is how this confounds
predictions that people love to make
about what's going to happen you know
the old recency principle of what
happened recently that'll probably
happen again people are saying I think
Fabiano is going to do it again well
nothing could be further from reality
than what's happening in this event and
Magnus has to win given what happened in
Norway another principle you know almost
an axiom in some people's mind and look
what's happening you know all of is the
same exactly walks away and and now
we've got LaVon in front I mean this the
people in London you know should be
grateful to all of us folks in the
colonies for coming up with such an
exciting preparatory tournament for
their event the London Classic well of
course nothing would happen without your
your great contribution to the game of
chess as well as your wife who was doing
quite great work as well she's
absolutely amazing you know she has for
30 or 40 years worked very hard in Boy
Scouts first in California and now back
here in the promised land of Missouri
and you know she was instrumental in
getting the chess merit badge
inaugurated just a few years ago and
already 100,000 Boy Scouts have earned
the chess merit badge which is
phenomenal I mean just it be lies you
know the lies belief I know you're
spreading your mish
is not just a spread professional chess
here in st. Louis but to spread
scholastic chess as well yes we're in
well I say were in well over a hundred
schools that's gonna jump very markedly
because we just got several new sponsors
ascension being one of them and their
sponsorship involves us going into
another whole district taking over all
of the schools in that district so we're
moving like 20 schools at a time so
before this week's over we might be
committed to like 150 160 schools I mean
it's just amazing the way it's been
accepted in the way the schools have
responded when we started joy and I
thought you know we're gonna have to
hire our sales person to go out and talk
to these schools about what we're doing
we never hired that sales person we
can't keep up with the demand
and it's a great problem to have it is a
fantastic problem to have so now let's
make you sweat a little bit what do you
think of the games today so far which
you have your eye on any game well yeah
the Aronian game I mean he his Ananda's
up a pawn but I assume that's temporary
I don't see how that that pawn a
majority of one survives for very long
and I've been wrong before that's about
I think as far as I'll go and well you
know there's a carload game I listened
to what you said I have to agree with
Yashiro with two rooks and two bishops
everything developed I don't know how
anybody could be in any great
disadvantage total material equality
look at this yes another person trying
to take over our job as a commentator
you do it enough Rex we really
appreciate all work I won't give up my
day job I'll stick with what I know an
absolute joy to always talk with you and
thank the man who has done so much to
create such resurgence in chess ear to
st. Louis around the country and even
around the world thank you so much
pleasure Rex Sinquefield he's the man
couldn't do anything without him Rex I
can't let you go without giving a teeing
you up for one question because we've
had these discussions numerous times
the idea of chess and Alzheimer's and
whether chess can help people with
dementia and other
challenges you have commissioned a study
or working to Commission a study with
Slough if you could just talk about that
for a second and why you find that in an
intriguing study well I was interested
in the topic for a variety of reasons
the most personal one is when I played
golf with in a charity golf tournament
with Mike Matheny the manager of the
Cardinal several years ago we played
together for 18 holes and obviously we
had very many lengthy conversations
about many subjects but that was one
that was dear to him because as Mike
pointed out he had 16 concussions when
he played in the major leagues as a
catcher he said early in his career it
took a serious collision to cause when
he said but later in my career it took a
foul ball tipped off my mask and there'd
be another one for two years following
baseball when he retired he said I'd be
out doing errands and I forget why I was
there I'd have to call my wife and say
where am I going and why if he said so
I'm very concerned about this now but
Mike does an amazing thing you know he
coaches a game all day or all evening
then he goes home and he does 20 minutes
of tactics on chest comm which I find to
be the most difficult thing to do in
chess and he does at 10:30 11:00 at
night and he said it relaxes him there's
got to be something wrong with him if
that relaxes so we got very interested
in this topic and the man who's married
to my niece dr. seuss Lavin is the
associate dean at the Medical School of
Saint Louis University and I raised the
possibility of doing a study and he
assembled some great scholars led by dr.
Lauren Swartz a psychologist she's got
some psychiatrists there and they have
put together a proposal which this best
Chess Club is sponsoring to look at the
effects of chess and its ability to
forestall Alzheimer's and dementia well
speaking of the Cardinals are they gonna
lose the World Series this year to the
Yankees you know to my New York Yankees
to your New York Yankees you know it's
possible that the orbit of the moon
would speed up and go twice its normal
rate but I don't think that will happen
nor do I think the Cardinals will lose
to the Yankees oh my lord
I will get into that one off-camera Rex
and I have fun with that guys back to
you